I have been working at Anaconda for more
than four years almost five years now I
am passionate about the open source
python ecosystem and the data science
Community that's why I contributed and
created some python packages and also
volunteer at various non-focused paidata
Scipio conferences I also have a data
science and machine learning book club
if you are interested in reading books
with us come join my book club
um
yeah let's get started so in this talk
we're going to talk about why we are
talking about explainable AI
um what does explainable Ai and how do
you what kind of methods you can use to
explain your black box models and what
kind of tools you can use
okay let's start it what let's get
started with why
first of all being able to explain your
models help you make decisions
facilitate decisions for your internal
stakeholders and internal customers
here's an example from LinkedIn LinkedIn
has this um sales model where it's
predicting whether a customer is likely
to churn or upsell I know a lot of
companies have this kind of model I have
done a charm model before it's very
popular so unnecessary
but then when as data scientists give
sales team this this result okay so this
account X is likely to upsell or likely
to churn uh the sales team is like okay
but why right the sales team still need
to take a lot of time and effort to dig
into why this account is likely to
upsell or turn to be able to talk to the
customer effectively
so LinkedIn created this
um product called crystal candle where
um
where essentially it extracted important
features that's important in predicting
the output and then rephrase it in a
narrative that normal people can
understand so even people who don't
understand data science they understand
how this model is predicted what factors
are important in predicting this account
likely being upsell so to the right here
you can see well the narrative here this
account is very likely to upsell its
likelihood is driven by those five
factors so with this information the
sales team is able to go to talk to the
customers and tell them okay so because
of those reasons I think I have a
perfect product for you and then they
can facilitate a much better effective
conversation with the customers
um
being able to explain your model not
only help your internal team but also
helps your customers here's an another
example with booking.com
booking.com is a travel agency with a
lot of hotels and private
um
home staying listed it's like Airbnb but
mostly for Europe I think
so at booking.com each property get this
one two three four five star ratings
right and then the property owners might
want to know so why is my property get
rated for four stars or three stars how
can I improve my property's rating so
with uh with some of the explainable
method they actually used Chef they were
able to
provide the property owners so here are
some features that may be contributing
to your property here are the highlights
and then they also have some recommended
features for each property to add if
they want to improve their rating
so I hope from those two concrete
examples you can see that being able to
explain your model actually really helps
with your internal stakeholders and your
customers and you can use the methods
right now to help your sales team your
marketing or your customers
okay the next important part regulations
and compliant compliances a lot of times
even when the models don't have race and
gender in their model the model is still
biased
because of some other variables and we
see a lot of news on there for example
Apple cars credit assessment algorithm
discriminated against women so I think
being being able to explain the model
and understand how model performs we'll
be able to catch certain biases early on
before launching
being able to explain your model is
really really hard as you can see later
in this presentation but debugging might
be even harder
um so here's an example uh there is
here's an example of a x-ray model where
we're predicting diseases from patients
X-Ray Scan
researchers found that they found the
model performed perfectly during
training and validation but it doesn't
really work in real life so they want to
know why so researchers used integrated
gradient to highlight the pixels that
contributed to the model prediction so
you can see the highlighted area to the
left there in the square and then when
you zoom in you can see the model is not
actually predicting diseases but
actually predicting the pen marks by the
doctors so that's quite interesting
right so now with this integrated
gradient method you're able to tell why
is my model wrong
and that goes into the next one trust
you want to know if you are able to
trust your model you want your
stakeholders to sign off your model to
understand your model is trustworthy
before launching here's an example using
lime where
uh we're predicting either this text
email message is classified as acetam or
question and you can see the words
highlighted here that's contributing to
the prediction it's actually irrelevant
with the classification so this Pro this
model is probably not that trustworthy
and then finally very important thing is
model monitoring uh
so the when we traditionally when we
monitor our model in production we
monitor model drift uh distribution
changes but those are really good
metrics but doesn't look into the inner
work of your model necessarily you may
want to check whether your feature
attribution changes over time here's an
example I got from Google where you get
the feature address attribution score
for each feature and you plot it over
time so if the feature of attribution of
a certain feature changes dramatically
you will know that something must be
wrong with my model so this tells you
directly why with something go wrong and
which feature goes wrong
so model monitoring very important
um
yeah I hope I know I have convinced you
it's important to understand your model
uh even though I feel like people are
all about chbt nowadays nobody cares
about explain the way AI but uh this is
still very important uh in actually
daily practice
so we'll just explain about AI uh here
is a formal definition from this book
I'll let you read it I will not uh read
it but basically you want to be able to
describe your model's action in a
explainable way that whoever is
consuming the model's prediction is able
to understand you whether it's sales
team whether it's customer whether it's
marketing whether it's product so be
able to understand your model's actions
there are a lot of
methods and research and schools of
thoughts in this field so I'm trying I'm
going to trying to
um bucket all those methods into
different buckets so help us understand
different methods and also help us to
get a big picture of the field
okay so first of all we have model
Centric methods and data Centric methods
model Centric methods focuses on the
internal of the model the model
infrastructure the model architecture
model features and so on data Centric
methods focus on specific data points
that's in your training data or from
another external data set that provides
some some meaning
so in the data centering methods we also
have example based influence functional
based and concept based methods so uh so
you want to know what kind of change in
your data could make a difference in
your prediction and concept based method
is really really interesting you want to
know whether a concept is important in
your prediction for example if the
concept of stripe is important in
classifying an image as a zebra
so that's that
model Centric methods we have postal
post-home methods and intrinsic methods
intrinsic methods are inherently
explainable models which are linear
regressions let's just regressions
decision tree General linear models and
generalized editing models so those
models you can
I mean we often start with those models
those are explainable you can just use
your coefficients to see the model
important the feature importance
and then for the postal methods those
are methods that's observed after the
model is trained and we can further
break it down into local methods cohort
and Global methods local methods focuses
on one data point at a time so why
doesn't this predict about why why is
this instance predicted a certain way
cohort and Global looks like the whole
training data look at one specific
feature for example and cohort is just a
subset of global that's why they're kind
of treated the same
and then you can further break it down
into model specific methods for example
some of the models only working with
some types of models like Tree Shop
works with
tree I don't know decision tree kind of
models tree based models deep deep shap
works with neuronex work neural network
based models integrated ingredient
integrated gradient works for models
that can be differentiable
and model agnostic approach works for
any type of models
like kernel shop lime you might think
this is amazing this is what I want to
use right but that comes with a big
computation cost so sometimes you need
to do the trade-off
and also with cohort and Global methods
we also have model specific model
agnostic and hybrid methods hybrid
methods are basically the aggregated
local
um explainable am values that's on the
left
so yeah so here's the the overall
picture of the the methods and I didn't
list all the methods here just some of
the representative measures methods and
and there are a lot more you can use
um I hope this is helpful
okay so we have talked about why we have
talked about what now let's talk about
how
I'm going to go through uh four methods
four examples for you uh just provide
you a basic intuition of how those
methods work you might have already
familiar with all the methods since uh
other methods here are pretty popular
especially chef and lime are very
commonly used
um yeah I'm gonna talk about tabular
data with shap image data with
integrated gradient text Data with lime
and then most interesting and fun method
that I think is a tcaf uh
note that shap integrated gradient and
line works for all types of data not
just limited to the
individual data types I'm listed here
but I'm not going to go through them for
the time's sake
how many people have used chef
yay cool
um yeah chef and Champion values are
interchangeable sometimes sharply values
is the theory from Game Theory and shap
is the Implement Implement
implementation and also the the library
that you can calculate shopping values
um so initially shopping values is from
Game Theory imagine a collaborative game
people can join teams and contribute to
the game we have four players
we want to calculate what is the
contribution of each player to this game
so supposedly we want to calculate the
contribution of player one so player one
can form uh can form teams with player 2
or form teams with player 203 and player
one may contribute differently depending
on who which Coalition player one is in
so essentially the calculation is to
calculate the weighted average of player
one's contribution to all possible
correlations
pretty straightforward right
uh in the uh in a machine learning model
case here is a the output or shampoo
value
from a machine learning model imagine we
have a model the base rate of the model
which is the output the expected value
of the output is 0.1 and now we have an
individual a female that's 65 years old
BMI is 40 and the model predictive 0.4
for this individual and we want to
understand why is this individual
prediction is 0.4 and how there's a
difference between the base array of 0.1
and the predicted value for this
individual of 0.4 so Sharpie value can
explain this difference as you can see
to the right here
um the sharply value of H is 0.46 is
negative 0.3 BP is 0.1 and BMI is 0.1
and if you add them add them up together
that is 0.3 so the Chevrolet values of
this all those features contributed to
the difference between the base rate and
the output
yeah so that's the uh the answer you
would get from a shafty value and it
will tell you how exactly each attribute
each feature contributed to the model
there are actually a lot of algorithms
to calculate shafty values I'm going to
go through one of them to give you a
intuition so imagine we have a house
production model we have four features
we have the housing style number of
bedrooms number of bathrooms House age
we want to understand why does this
instance X1 X2 3x4 predicted the house
price of
390k the way we do it if we want to
calculate okay what is the contribution
of the number of bathrooms here
so the step one is to sample
um it's do random sample a sample from
the training data we call it
z1z2z3z4 and we permutate the features
now the X parenthesis one was actually
X2 and then we create two new instances
we call it X plus 3 and x minus three
um you can see the difference between
those are uh just just the the X3 and Z3
is different one is using the original
uh
number of bathrooms from the uh interest
instance Z3 is the sample data and then
you calculate the difference between the
output value of those two instances
so that's how you calculate sharply
values okay not yet you still need to do
this uh this algorithm many many times
and then you can get the sharply value
for the number of bathrooms features
and and again I said there there is
there is Kernel shop Tree Shop deep shop
where different purposes I link the
shaft documentation for you to take a
look if you're interested
okay the second method I wanted to give
you an intuition on is integrated
gradient
uh our image data so this is the one of
the seniency methods basically it will
highlight the pixels that contribute to
predicting this image being a cockatoo
so you can see there are the areas near
the eyes and the neck and the Rings and
wings are kind of highlighted in purple
here and then this is how you can you
can tell which pixels are important you
can guess like which areas might be
important in predicting or classifying
this image
as suggested from the name this method
is a gradient based however uh one issue
with using raw gradient is that once the
model has learned
um this this image is a Kaka two any
change in a specific pixel won't change
the model prediction anymore which means
the gradient will just be zero it would
just be flat uh this is also called
gradient saturation in this case so
integrate great integrated gradient
solve this issue by using this series
image created a straight line in image
path from the Baseline to the Implement
image you can see here is a serious
image here so to the right here our
Alpha equals 1 is the original image to
the left Alpha equals 0 is the base
image
so you might wonder okay so why is the
base image black here that's just a very
good question that's actually one of the
limitations of this method because you
have to choose what kind of Base image
you you want and choosing different base
image may result in different different
results
you can choose black or white or blur or
completely noisy
um
yeah so so that's that and you can see
the equation here
and then in practice you're actually
using Riemann sums to approximate the
integrated gradient I'm not going to go
through the equations but if you're
interested you can take a look at my
slides
okay I also linked two uh tutorials with
code from two different libraries
yeah if you're interested go take a look
okay the next one lime how many of you
have used or heard of lime
yay cool
do you like it
um okay lime is one of the most popular
methods uh it's called Loco
interpretable interpretable model
agnostic explanations I think the reason
why it's popular because the library is
super easy to use and this method is
actually really easy to understand I
think I don't know
um so okay here we go so meditation on
Lime is the first sample points around
the original input with slight
perturbations so the original input
you're interested in is this a big red
Plus in the center there and you want to
understand okay why is big plus
predicted a certain way
and then you get all those different
samples around your original input
the second step is to fit a explainable
linear model which is the dashed line on
the samples weighted by the distance to
the given input instance that's why you
can see some of the dots are bigger than
the others the big the closer it is from
this original input we're interested in
the bigger or the bigger weight it is
okay and then we can use this linear
approximation to explain the local
behavior of a complex model because if
we're using a simple linear model it is
explainable
uh in the
um in the event of using line for text
Data uh it's basically it's basically
the same thing so when you create new
samples you just you just uh randomly
replace words with phrases as you can
see to the right here and you might
wonder okay so you mentioned you need to
wait the samples by the distance how do
I calculate the distance of those
perturbated samples with the original
sample there are multiple ways to do
that as well cosine distance is a
popular one and then there are other
options you can try
okay so
um the result of using lime looks like
this that we have seen before that you
will just highlight the
um attributing words in your text file
to see which one is important in
predicting certain classes in this
example
okay I linked a live tutorial here again
if you're interested we don't have time
to go through it please take a look
the final method I want to mention tcaf
how many of you have heard about tcaf
no
okay cool okay this is one of my
favorite methods uh it's pretty cool so
when we have saliency methods we're
looking at each individual pixels and
how each individual each individual
pixel contributed to the prediction and
then when you look at the whole image by
itself you're like guessing
is that area like neck is that area eyes
like you're guessing what is relevant
what does the highlighted pixel mean in
the saliency methods
so keycap solved that problem by testing
the concept instead of pixels directly
so for example decaf is using TCAP you
can test whether this concept of stripe
is important in predicting this image
being a zebra
pretty amazing right I think it's
amazing okay so here are five steps to
calculate tcaf
first of all you need to Define your
concept of Interest
for example
uh
the upper row of a here is a data set of
stripe images
okay this is the main limitation of
decaf that you need to find a database
of the concept you're interested in
which could be really hard and also
defining a concept that can be testable
is also really hard like sometimes you
want your concept to be
specific and not too high level because
you want to find the images that could
work
so luckily there is a broadband data set
which
include very include a bunch of low
level
concept images for example stripe dots
zigzag this paper actually is using the
broaden data set
the next step is calculate the concept
activation vectors
the way it works is that we have the
stripe stripe image on the upper row of
a we also have a random image random
setup image the lower level of a and you
pass those images to your uh your model
whichever layer you want to test on here
is using layer l and then you train a
linear classifier to separate the output
between the strapped image and the
random image and cab is the bacteria
orthogonal to the classification
boundary which is the vvcl here
Okay so
the third step is to calculate the
directional derivatives and which is the
conceptual sensitivity which means if
you change uh if you change this cap how
much with the onput change which means
how much
how much is the model sensitive to the
change of this concept
okay now we can calculate t cap I know
this equation doesn't make any sense to
you basically you calculate the uh
directional derivatives for all your
images and among those who among those
images that are classified as um zebra
how many of them has the derivative
has the directional derivative greater
than one which means the stripe is
making a positive contribution to that
image
and then those might not make sense it's
okay uh step five last step is to
statistically test TCAP scores
um because even if your tcaf score is
positive uh you don't know if it is
significantly meaningful so you do this
process many many times with different
random images you get a distribution of
your of your t cap for your concept and
you can also get your Baseline
distribution by replacing your constant
image with random images so instead of
having concept versus random uh train
the linear model you can do random
versus random train the linear model and
get the calf so and then you can get a
distribution of the tcat scores for the
random and random images as the Baseline
and you can use t-test to test whether
TCAP is significant or not
so yeah so that's how you can calculate
tcaf
um and then I have linked two tutorials
on TCAP for you to take a look uh I hope
you find it as exciting as I do
okay
next question you may all wonder how do
we choose there are so many different
models
that is a great question uh well like
many cases it depends
uh
in moreover this is a field of action
research a lot of researchers have their
own opinions some people say don't use
lime some people say use lime so it's
like very confusing uh
yeah so
I listed two references I find super
important and useful for me when I when
I try to decide on different models so
it's explainable AI for practitioners
this book listed a lot of more methods
than the methods I have go through today
yeah for each method it has a table of
pros and cons so you can evaluate
yourself
and then Captain have this algorithm
comparison Matrix you can take a look
okay final section tools we all love
tools some of you might not like math
but like if you can get your hands dirty
you can get started using it without
understanding things
um okay there are a lot a lot of tools
to choose from so if you only want to
use Chev lime tcaf uh just use the the
corresponding libraries those libraries
are really good at
specific at those specific tasks if you
want to try saliency methods like
integrated gradient or many other
financing methods you can use the
saliency library what I like to do is to
try all that seven methods and see which
methods make sense or combine them to
make your own decisions
and by explaining has a bunch of methods
you can use interpretable ml I like that
model I like this open source Library it
has a good drop down dashboard you can
ex you can explore and also if you use
pytorch models use Captain because
Captain is designed to explain pytorch
models
and then there are a lot of vendor
options uh so if you're using
I don't know Google to Cloud AWS
snowflake whatever just do whatever your
vendor is available
to for you to do explainable AI
if you want to learn more uh I listed
two books that I really like
uh I actually chatted with the book
authors uh in my book club last month if
you're interested take a look at the
video oh yeah the authors provide very
good information on different methods
and then here are my references thank
you so much
[Music]